Propagation. Look, the is the Allahh.
The propagation,
my friend. My friend, are you telling me
if Okay. If the Sahabah did not
propagate it, would the Quran be
preserved? Yes. How? Because it would
literally stay in the same condition
that it came in because the prophet
wrote it down. How? How? How? Look,
there's no sab. The prophet Muhammad
teach
him down. The revelation came down.
There was no Sahabah. How would the
Quran be preserved come to us? Listen,
it's if it's if the people didn't.
Brothers and sisters, it is the winter
season in the UK. Today in my house, my
boiler broke and the house was freezing
cold. My kids are wearing jackets. I'm
trying to find heating and as a father,
I'm trying to make sure my kids, my wife
are warm. Imagine the people around the
world. I'm working with one of my
brothers, 100% donation policy charity
who are helping Syria, Lebanon, and
Afghanistan. People who are freezing to
death intense brothers and sisters.
Donate whatever you can because today's
experience with me showed me subhan
Allah how vulnerable we are and just
made me remember those people who are in
need. Whatever you donate guys even if
it is one pound help those people in
those countries. Listen to me Muhammad.
Muhammad listen to me. Yeah. Is it an
interrogation or a discussion? No no no
Muhammad we we said very clearly we're
going to ask you one simple question.
One simple question. If someone said to
me how did you come here today? And I go
one second. One second. Let me let me
explain you from the beginning brother.
How? It's not from the beginning. One
second. One second. Just a minute. You
want me to You want me to quote some
people I don't believe in? No. No. No.
No. You're being like the Christians.
You're like, you're being like the
Christians. It's very
simple. So the people who given the book
and there's your position by God
himself. Muhammad. Muhammad. One
question.
You don't take from no problem. Okay.
I'm asking a simple question and I will
ask you because it's I'll be I'll be
honest with you. To me it seemed that
I'll be honest with you. I'm an expert
on this. I don't know this topic. I will
not even talk to Quranist. Yeah. There's
only one thing. You're talking to one,
right? No, no, no. I know. You know why?
Because there's only one thing I'm
really confident about and it is this
question which is what otherwise this
you know I'm a guy that you never let us
answer. You're going to say how the
Quran came to you but you never let us
finish the answer. You you interrupted
me three times. I you're waiting for
you're waiting for an answer you want. I
have an answer that's different than
yours. You have to hear my answer and
then you can try to take charge. You're
not qualified. You're not qualified to
give to give. No, he's not qualified to
give exes on the Quran. As simple as
that. I don't. But as if you as if as if
the ex Jesus that came from your side is
qualified to explain the Quran when it's
wrong and contradictory. Muhammad. Okay,
let's forget about exist for a second.
Can I look I I believe I'm a lay man.
I'm Ali Daw. I'm a lay man. I'm not a
student of knowledge. I wouldn't even
call myself a D. I'm a YouTuber. I'm a
simple YouTuber, Muslim who does this
basic. That's what I call honesty. Good.
That's what I am. That's what I am. I
don't need to make myself something I'm
not. I do confront the far right. Let me
finish. I confront the far right. I do a
bit of nsia. I do a da to the
non-Muslims. I love my lane. I'm on the
hard shoulder. Yeah. The hard shoulder
is not. Yeah. Okay. I'm asking you a
simple question because I believe this
question intellectually knocks you out.
How did the Quran come to me? How did it
come to us?
The prophet wrote it down and people
propagated it. Okay. The prophet wrote
it down. The prophetam cannot read. All
right. So the prophet according to who?
Okay. No problem. Let's go with it. You
have you
have Okay.
What? What does it mean in Arabic?
Gentile.
Unlettered. Unlearned. Unlearned.
Unlearned. Unlearned. No. No. Let me
prove the point. You ask a question and
then you don't let me speak. This is
This is really weird. This is really
weird. This is an interrogation. This is
not a discussion. This is how you guys
don't show your civil side for us to
have a proper good discussion. It's not
fair. You're doing what Muhammad does.
You just say Muhammad Muhammad Muhammad.
You don't let me listen or you don't let
me answer. You don't listen. I Your name
is Muhammad, but you don't follow the
Muhammad. Yeah. No, I follow I follow
the prophet. Your your name is Ali. You
your name is Ali and you follow Abu. So
maybe you should name your change your
name to Abuhur. You're taking shots at
my name when you said you don't want
adhan minutes. Yeah, that comment. Don't
you No. Wait, wait, wait. What? Didn't
is it in your hadith that Allah chose my
name?
I mean I mean Okay. So one more time.
Yeah. Did didn't Allah didn't Allah give
me the name Muhammad? I think you should
according to your hadith. He said to me
the prophet wrote it down. I'm going to
I'm going to go with that for the sake
of argument. So the prophet wrote it
down and he brought it.
The propagation is whoever wanted to uh
work in the way of God. So there was
propagation but it's not preservation.
The preservation was with God. Okay. So,
how did So, how did the Quran get
preserved? By God and his messenger.
Okay. How
done? But I would like to explain the
position when God really No, let me I
already answered you. I already answered
you. I already answered you. Ali, God
and his messenger. Yeah. Oh, I got I got
I got my Quran. I got my Quran from
FedEx driver. I got I got my Quran from
a FedEx driver. Should I take his
hadith? I'm a lay man. Muhammad, you can
quote Quran. I can't even do that. I got
I got my Quran from FedEx delivery.
Muhammad, can you quote the Quran? Yeah,
some of it. Okay. It's quite
Okay. So, why are you debating me if you
don't know the Quran? You're calling me
a Quranist and you don't know the Quran.
Why are you here? And that's my point.
You just made my point for me. You are
not Okay. Why are you debating me if you
clearly don't know? I haven't even
finished two. You are not debating. I
haven't even two sentences. Okay. I'm
saying to you, you are you can call the
Quran in Arabic this that okay I don't
even have I can read the Quran etc. I
can I've got it from memory as well as
well not all of it but I'm saying
someone like me the reason I've brought
the camera to me is to show people
people look at me and go Ali is not
advanced for this topic. I'm even
showing you that even I can ask you a
question you cannot answer. No, I just
answered it, but you're not you're not
you're not letting me explain the answer
because you are a person who wants to
just justify your scholars, not God. The
word of God for you is circular
reasoning. How did the Quran get
preserved?
By God and his messengers done. But one
second Ali Ali, one second. One second.
We both know that the hadith and the
Quran were not preserved in the same
manner. There is no weak verse or verse
or verse. It's all correct. One, two,
one, two, two. Okay.
One second. Yeah. So, so when God when
God says in the Quran that when people
used to hear the Quran, they believe
that it knew they knew from it. It's
from God. So now when we're hearing the
Quran, we know it's the truth from God.
And now God within this book, the
content itself is telling us he's
preserving the remembrance. So now you
want me to doubt it or or wait one
second. We both know that the
preservation is a miracle. Just like how
Jesus is birth is a miracle. So you're
telling me, prove to me how Jesus has no
father. This is the same question you're
asking me. Prove to me how the Quran
stayed preserved, not how did it get
preserved. We know how it got preserved
by God. You're saying how did it stay
preserved? That's the miracle. Like
you're saying how to a miracle. How did
Moses How did Moses split the sea? I'm
waiting for you. Tell me how Moses split
the sea. Okay. What the what? M M Alam
Jesus miracles was a supernatural thing.
The Quran is also preservation can be
supernatural. It is supernatural as
well. Can be or it is. It is. It is
correct. But but I'm telling you how
once I listen to you I'm asking the
question again. You're not answering. I
said to you how was it preserved? For
example, Mus Alam splitting the sea.
It's a supernatural event that's
happening. The Quran's preservation.
It's a promise from Allah subhanaa tala
which is a miracle but I'm saying how
did that preservation happen because
there's a methodology to you accepted
and said the hadith and the Quran the
way it was narrated was different of
course the Quran is there are
some now I'm asking you a simple
question I said to you how did the Quran
come to us and how was it preserved the
first one you accepted which is that the
prophet said and they propagated it
propagation means the following but you
missed you missed you missed you missed
something the prophet preserved it He's
he wrote it. Let me finish. Why are you
stopping me? Look, let me finish.
Propagation means the following. I'm
going to propagate now that my apple
juice that I make is the best apple
juice. I'm going to go tomorrow to
Bradford and tell everybody, brother,
ladies and gentlemen, I want to say that
this apple juice I have here is the best
apple juice you would ever have in your
life. I'm propagating it. Now, those
people are going to be asked, "What did
you do today?" Oh, I was in Stratford
today in a shopping center and a and a
gentleman, you know, you know, he was
quite handsome gentleman. I mean, unless
you know, chef, you know, apple was
propagating that his apple juice was the
best apple juice. And now they're going
to go and tell somebody else that's
going to tell somebody else. They're
going to tell somebody else. Now, it
will be a mass conspiracy to come and
say, "We've got a thousand people saying
the news coverage, they're like, "Okay,
who is this man complaining saying that
his apple juice is the best apple
juice?" Now, it will be a mass
conspiracy to come and say all of those
people that said they witnessed Ali
saying
was a mass conspiracy. They came
together and lied. You said propagation.
Now that if that is the case, that means
when the prophet came and
said,
"Alhamdulillah, people have this." Okay.
Now the Sahabah you accept there was
Sahabah that lived of course there's
people around the prophet hearing now
heard this one second the Sahabah heard
this now hundreds heard it thousands
heard it it became now they go and tell
the order it comes back to us let me
finish these are presumptions I'm nearly
done it comes back to us unless you come
to come and say this is a mass
conspiracy now if you accept you accept
the Quran was preserved like this yes or
no no I preser the Quran was preserved
by the hand of the prophet himself and
the people propagated. You even have
hadith in your own books that state that
do not take the Quran. Listen, let let
me say let me answer. There's a
difference between propagation and
preservation. Okay. Something preserved
and someone propagating is different.
Now the you said how it was preser uh
preserved, not how it was propagated.
The propagation is for no people they
strived in the way of God. Now, if
someone is telling me a hadith in your
books that the prophet ordered not to
take copies of the Quran to hostile
territories, that means it was written
down because it's not like they're going
to surgically remove it from their
brain. And by the way, the longest surah
in the longest verse in the Quran is the
one in Bakar in regards to writing
debts. So, are you telling me that
people around the prophets were hearing
that they have to write down debts, but
they would not write down the Quran?
Okay. Would you do you accept that
propagation is preservation? Yes. No.
No, it's not. Tell me one second. Can
you please tell me how propagation is
not preservation? If that's the case,
how do I have the Quran today? Well, the
preservation factor is the miracle from
God. What propagation is copy paste?
Okay, one second. Allah said he would
preserve the you said I said to you
propagation preserve the zikur the
zikar. One sec. One sec.
Propagation. Look, the is the of Allahh.
The propagation will Quran reveal. My
friend, my friend, are you telling me if
the Okay. If the Sahabah did not
propagate it, would the Quran be
preserved? Yes. How?
Because it would literally stay in the
same condition that it came in because
the prophet wrote it down. How? How?
How? Brother, look, there's no Sahabah.
Sahabah doesn't exist. The prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him, he
revelation came down. The revelation
came down. There were no Sahabah. How
would the Quran be preserved and come to
us? Listen, it's if it's if the people
didn't one second. If the people didn't
do the work, then the Quran wouldn't
come to you. You're right. But that does
not necess preserved it. No, I'm telling
you about propagation. People worked.
No, no, no. Let me finish because you
think you got me in a catch. But you're
not listening. The problem is you're not
listening. Let me finish. Let me finish
the point. Let me finish the point.
Okay. What I'm saying is that God knew
that the people will be working in the
way of God as God clearly states in the
Quran. Okay?
He didn't
say now I want to take you to a very
simple thing very simple easy thing if
you're claiming that if if it's oh sure
sure Sure sure uh uh if we if we go to a
very simple verse where you guys keep
claiming that the hadith and the Quran
go hand in hand in unison and the hadith
is the right and the Quran that's the
book of god so is
the is is the hadith and obviously
theool can uh abregate the word of god
but let's go to the verse in chapter 2
when God
says why is it why is it singular not
be so it's not two things it's one thing
because both of them are revelation from
no look no sh I I asked you a question
look I said to you if look I need to
look look this is this is I debate
Christian you're confusing preservation
and propagation to you I listen to you
brother you went on a tangent I'm
telling I'm bringing you back. Yeah.
Do like a revelation was revealed to him
in the middle of I can't I can't hear
you. People are talking. I can't hear
you.
Guys, guys. Okay. Now I repeat again. I
asked you a simple question, two
questions. How the Quran came to us was
and how it was preserved. I said to you
propagation is preservation. You didn't
answer. But that doesn't make sense.
Let's let's look up the word
propagation. What it means? It does not
mean preservation. No, my friend. My
friend, one second. Simple question. No,
I'm propagating a preserved book doesn't
mean I preserved it. My friend, it's not
a part of proper. I did answer you.
You're just defining words as you want.
The fact that you couldn't answer me, a
YouTuber, a simple day-to-day Muslim. I
asked you a simple question. The Quran
is revealed to the prophetam. There is
no
Sahaba. How will the Quran come to me
today? So, so I'm I'm looking I'm
looking at the definition of propagation
that has nothing to do with
preservation. The definition of
propagation
the action of
can you can you can you put that show?
Yes. The action of widely spreading and
promoting an idea theory a life devoted
to the propagation of the Catholic
faith. So it's the this example or
promoting an idea or a theory. Good. Now
can can you read the example? Can you
read the example that they put? Can can
read the example. A life devoted to
propagation of the Catholic faith. Yeah.
The Catholic faith is preserved.
According to your definition, the
Catholic faith is the uh preserved.
They're propagating a false idea. No,
actually he's giving an example. Thank
you very much. Yes. Yes. So the Catholic
faith according to your definition means
that it's been preserved. That then now
you're saying that Jesus is the son of
God and he died for your sins. Good job,
bro. You you just you just embarrassed
yourself with the definition. Now we're
going to see who actually got
embarrassed. You know they say that the
one who laughs the last laughs the best.
Beautiful. You're the ones laughing the
whole day. I'm going to laugh on the day
of judgment when God shows you that the
Quran is sufficient. Thank you. That was
emotional. You touched my heart. Now,
no, it wasn't. It wasn't. It wasn't. It
wasn't. I'm debating two and a half men
cuz you called me a half man would beat
me. I'm I'm debating the half man. Can I
Can I look listen listen? I I'm I'm the
half man here and you're getting
finished. I accept the half man. You're
not. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. According to you,
the Catholic faith is preserved because
it's been propagated. Of course. Can I
Can I Can I reply? You said of course it
is. The Catholic faith is preserved. So
that means what they're saying is truth.
Can I can I reply? One sec. What's can I
reply?
Thank you. Thank you. So now this is the
last laugh. Yeah. This is giving you an
example of how you could use that. And
he gave the example of Christianity. It
could have been Judaism. It could have
been Hinduism. It could have been Islam.
Do you see what I mean? So don't laugh
too early. But but but let's talk let's
talk about the word propagation. When
someone's propagating, he can propagate
falsehood and manipulate it. It's still
propagation. Now I know now. No, no, no.
You're just running away from the Quran.
My friend, I'm going to the Quran. The
Wii has come down. The prophet wasallam.
There is no
sahaba. How did the Quran come to us?
Well, if you want to talk about
theoretical questions, then it's the
same thing that can be applied to the
hadith. The simple question, the simple
answer is that the prophet wrote it down
and because people embraced Islam
because of the truth from God because
the content of the book. So when people
heard the Quran, when the prophet was
talking, when he was reciting the Quran,
people will say this is the truth. They
didn't have an isnad. They didn't have
proof. The only proof that they had was
the content of the book. So the content
of the book is what drives people to
Islam. You know this very well. When
you're doing da'a, you give a free copy
of the Quran cuz if you gave them nine
books of Bkari, the person will go
through a 100 walls and they have to
accept this falsehood for them to accept
your religion. The Quran is pure and
simple. So when the Quran is saying that
itself has been preserved by God, that's
not circular reason. I follow the
prophet and I use the Quran as a
criterion and as a judge between people.
So when I when I quote the Quran, I'm
quoting the word of God. That is the
final quote the word. There is no
circular reason. God is telling me he
preserved the book. So, I'm reading a
book that's preserved. It's very simple.
I don't know why you're asking a
disbeliever question. If an atheist
comes to me and he tells me, "How do you
know the book is from God?" I'm not
going to say because of this magic
isnad. I'm going to say because of the
content. The way that God is being
described, the way that your
relationship has to be with God, the way
that your relationship has to be with
your parents, and the way that you're
supposed to approach the your life is
very extremely well detailed in the
Quran. It's teaching you a psyche, a
psychology to teach to uh to react with
other disbelievers and mushiks and to
act with the believers. It's very
simple. The book is simple and you guys
make it very complicated. All right
guys, I just want to tell you guys that
you can order a guided prayer for free
in learn how to pray salah with getting
some donations. You can donate uh
towards the project. We're teaching
people how to pray salah, how to do mud,
how to memorize the Quran. Um so I just
felt I just sorry I had to add that
there quickly. We do a fundraiser. But I
just felt like me asking a Christian
about the Trinity and then he gives me a
sermon. You literally gave me a sermon
about, you know, being good to mothers,
forefathers. One second. One second. Let
me finish, bro. One second, man. I
listen to you. I listen to you. I didn't
interrupt you. I asked you one simple
question. And the more I ask a simp,
it's like, look, if I go to somewhere,
they say, "Did you steal the cookie from
the cookie jar?" And they go, "Yeah, but
you know what happened to my life and I
was going there, my mom hurt me, and
then sent me." Yeah. I'm asking a simple
question and I ask again, how did the
Quran get preserved? The prophet wrote
it. Where's the life story? Muhammed.
Look, I've been respectful. I didn't
call you names. Look, nothing. You You
call me a half a man. I I'm a half a
man. Call me a quart man. I'm a quart
man. You You're insulting me before I
came on. Listen, listen, listen. No
problem. Okay, cool man. Okay, now I'm
ask a simple question. The prophet Allah
subhana wa tala sends to the prophet
Muhammad wasallam and I'm going to ask
you this for the last time she know what
from now on I can debate Quranist. I'm
confident because he is their one of the
if oh I'm trying to sound arrogant.
Muhammad, one second. Muhammad, the wahi
sent down to the prophet Muhammad
wasallam. Mhm. How and there's no
Sahabah. How did the wahi the Quran's
preservation reach us?
But if there is no Sahab if there's no
Sahaba then he's not a messenger. Do you
understand that? If nobody if nobody no
if nobody believed the messenger then
he's not a messenger. That's the point.
No no no problem. You're making You're
making a You're asking You're asking.
This guy is asking. Listen. Listen. This
guy is asking, "Can God create a rock he
can't carry?" This guy just clearly
states, he clearly just asked, "Can God
create a rock he can't carry? Can a
messenger be sent and nobody believe
him?" Perfect. You just accepted that
there has to be someone he came to that
he revealed the Quran to that can
preserve. And he wrote it down. That's
the preservation. I for the Quran. I've
I've heard you. Let me speak. Now he
just Okay, brother. I'm I'm propagating
the Quran. Will you take my hadith? I'm
propagating the Quran. Will you I'm
propagating Quran. Will you take my
hadith? Listen. Listen. The FedEx the
FedEx guy. He's he's giving me a copy of
the Quran. Should I take his hadith now?
What are you doing? You're now
interrupting me. You know why? Cuz you
know you because No, I didn't get
caught. W This is so easy for anyone
with logic. with anyone with logic.
You're asking you're you're asking why
are you interrupting a quarter man? Let
the quarter man say his quarter. No,
because because I actually want to talk
about the Quran. Let me see. Look, I'm
going to give you another three minutes.
Yeah. Can Can we talk Can we talk about
the Quran or you still want to talk
about how the prophet wrote it down
about the Quran? I know you're not on
your body language.
Then then you're
no it's it's not uncomfortable. It's
stupid. I'm telling you. I want to talk
about what's inside the Quran. You want
to talk about history? Listen to you. I
have to No, you haven't. Let me ask a
question. Or are you interrogating me? I
did answer your question. Listen, I did
answer your question. Exactly. I did
answer your question, but you don't like
my answer. Let me speak. Now, you
admitted I asked you and said number
one, how did the Quran come to us? You
ignored that. How was it preserved? You
said, for example, that I told you the
FedEx driver gave it to me. How did I
ignore it? Let me finish. My friend, you
don't even have a FedEx driver because
you're saying there was nobody there.
Then you came and said I said if the
You're saying how did it came to me? If
the wahi came down, I said and there was
no people. How would it come? Cuz you're
talking about a miraculous way it will
be preserved with no people. The prophet
Muhammad wasallam gets the revelation
then you said oh no I can't get out of
you're confusing. You're confusing
propagation. You're confusing
propagation and preservation. I answered
these but I answered it. You're going in
a circle. Let me finish and then you can
talk. If you are confident about your
position, I listen to you. I'm like,
"Okay, let me hear him out." Okay. You
are keep interrupting me, which means
you are uncomfortable. That's why you're
moving around. I see you doing this
exercise, uh, shoulder stretches, this
that you're uncomfortable. Your body
language show you know that you know
that. Go ahead. Let me finish. Okay,
good. I said to you the wahi was
revealed the pro to prophetam because
you're talking about miracle. It's a
miracle. Alhamdulillah. Okay. There is
nobody. How did it come to us? What did
he say? He changed it and then he said
there could be no messenger if there's
no one to give the message to. Hug true.
Which means that if the message has to
be given and propagated to somebody and
that means what? That there has to be
people that it was revealed the told to
that what did those people do? Did they
keep it to theirel? No, it's the Quran.
You want to share it? Me I love talking
about the Quran. I want to share it with
people. Propagate it. Then what does
that mean? Propagation is preservation.
So the question I was asking let me let
me answer it. Let me answer be Oh my
god. How did the Quran did the Quran
come to us? How did the Quran come to
us? Please answer this. Okay. So, so you
made you made you made a fallacy here
because obviously the Torah, the Gospel,
and the Psalms, they were also books
from God that people also propagated,
but it failed preservation. And it's the
exact same thing with your hadith. The
reason why the Quran is different
because it's literally a miracle.
There's absolutely no book in history
that can take the exact same love and
care that the Quran did because it's
outside of the people's hands.
Propagation is not preservation.
Propagation is propagating what you
have. But people have manipulated the
other books of God. But this is the
problem with you people. You ask
questions and then you don't hear the
answer. You don't listen and you keep
going around in circles. I wanted to
talk about the content of the Quran. How
the Quran proves that it's sufficient.
You want to talk about history and
theoretical questions to prove credences
to people that I I will not be
questioned about. Is the Quran here?
Yes, it is. How did it get here is
irrelevant. What I need to do is follow
the Quran,
bro. So, one second. One second. One
second. One second. You took my
confidence with the Quran is from this
to this. No, she answer what does the
word maja mean? Guys, he said how the
Quran. Oh, you see, why don't you answer
the question? What does Miza mean?
something that cannot be explained,
right?
With all due respect, with all your
respect, brother.
No, no, no, no, no, no. You're an idiot
because you're you're not letting me
speak. Habibi, the Quran is about the
content. Do you understand what that
means? God is not going to ask me who's
the fourth person in the line. Do you
believe in the last two verses of
Of course. You believe in them? Yeah.
Yeah. The falsehood does not come
between its hand or behind it. So
there's no there's no added How do you
know where the is? How do I know the is
because God clearly states
in just like how in chapter 29. Well,
just one second.
Let me finish. Let me finish. Let me
finish. Let me finish. Let me finish.
Let me finish. Let me finish. This guy
so much. So much for a civil
decision. So
much. Let me
finish. Yeah. Yeah. That's it. That's
perfect. So God says in chapter 29,
So recite what has been revealed to you
and perform the prayer. And God is
saying to
Ml. So for me the Hold One second. One
second. One second. Hold on. Hold on. I
I didn't finish. No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I
don't care. I'm going to keep speaking
because it does not necessitate it
doesn't necessitate does not necessitate
for you to face.
is I'm telling you the meaning of you're
you're the finished. You don't know what
the meaning of means. I'm telling you
the meaning. I'm not telling you what to
do. I'm not telling you to make your
housel you weirdos. But you don't
listen. You guys are you guys are you
guys are inviting me to associate to God
what I don't have knowledge in. The
Quran is perfect. It does not need
anything. It does not need any contempl
any book to explain it. The Quran is
very clear. But you guys have a very big
problem with the Quran being sufficient.
So do you get revenge from us because we
believed in God and what was has been
revealed to you and what has been
revealed to us? Do you really do you
really think we're kafir because we
believe in the Quran? You think we're
kafir because we want to defend. You
guys don't call us kafirs. Have you
lost? Of course you are a cover. Yeah,
100%. You're a mushik. Okay, that's You
are a No, he's not.
Okay, my friend, you're a mushikah. Have
your last word. Have your last word. Oh,
I already had my last word. You you you
now make yourself a fool, please. Let me
just let you know you are going to be
famous for saying there is no it's not
relevant for us to know where the how
the Quran was clear to us.
Muhammad I'm telling you to I I said it
a million times that the that the
prophet wrote it down. I ask Allah to
guide you confidence for debate Quran. I
ask Allah to guide you to back Islam.
Thank you. Thank you. I love I love your
question. I love your question. Uh I
love I love your question. Okay. Yala
yala. Yeah. Sure. Sure. Sure. Run away.
That's fine. Run away. Run away. Just
interrogate and run away. Yes. I know
you interrogate and run away. Sunnis
Sunni special. They don't know how to
have it. I mean on camera I am running
away from an apple like yours. Thank
you. I'm running the opposite direction.
Okay. In my country they say my friend
away from me close to Allah subhanaa
tala. Even that is a lot.